Çeviri: Betül Tanrıkulu
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
Yaratıcı insan kimdir?
Bu soru niye
benim için önemli?
Çocukken Leonardo Da Vinci'nin
hikâyelerini dinledim.
Kendine kanat yapıp uçabilen bir insan.
O zamanlar benim için
büyücü gibi bir şeydi.
Yani, fizik bilmiyorum,
bir şey bilmiyorum.
Uçan bir insandan bahsediyoruz!
Zaman geçtikçe
diğer büyücülerle de tanıştım:
Havadan elektrik üretebilen Tesla,
atomu parçalayabilen Einstein,
bilgisayarları evimize getirmesine
önayak olan Steve Jobs
ve daha birçoğu.
Şimdi, siz çocukken bunları tanıyınca,
size bir büyülü geliyorlar.
Ve ne kadar büyüseniz de,
ne kadar öğrenseniz de,
ne kadar fizik bilseniz de,
bu büyülerini korumaya devam ediyorlar.
O yüzden ben de doğal olarak,
"Bu yaratıcı insanları
yaratıcı yapan nedir?"
bu soruyu sormaya başladım.
Ve sonra aslında sorunun cevabının
çok basit olduğunu fark ettim.
Hepsi çok çalışıyor!
Yani, yaratıcı olmanın bence
tek sırrı çok çalışmak.
İşte; havadan elektrik üretmek
üzerine projeler,
mobil aplikasyonlar,
kanserli çocuklara oyun gibi,
olabildiğince bir şeyler
katmaya çalıştım bu dünyaya.
Ve bunların hepsini
yapmak için çok çalıştım.
Okulda 8 saat derse gidiyordum,
geceleri eve geldim,
günlük tekrarlar yaptım.
Neredeyse sadece 4-5 saat uyuyarak
ailemle, arkadaşlarımla
çok az görüşerek
sürekli kod yazdım.
Tatillerde denize gitmedim,
haftasonları dışarı çıkmadım.
Ve hiç pişman değilim çünkü
zekâ ya da genetik avantaja
inanmıyorum.
İnsan sadece çalışarak
bunların hepsini başarabiliyor.
İnandırıcıydı, değil mi?
Ama aslında size yaklaşık bir dakikadır
yalan söylüyorum.
Yani, aralarında yaptığım şeyler de var
ama birçoğunu yapmadım.
O zaman çok çalışanlar mı gerçekten
üretici insanlar?
Evet, çalışmak gerekli, yani sonuçta
bir şey yapmak için
çalışmanız gerekiyor.
Ama çalışmak; sadece o yolu katetmek.
Bir amacınız, gideceğiniz bir yer
olmadıktan sonra
o yolda ne kadar gittiğinizin
çok bir önemi yok.
Bir fikir, bir vizyon olmadan,
ne kadar ilerlerseniz ilerleyin,
bir şey ifade etmiyor.
O zaman, bu sorunun cevabını
bulamadığım için,
yani, çok çalışanlar mı-
evet, çalışıyorlar ama
ama sadece bu değil.
"Başka ne olabilir?"
diye düşündüm.
Bunları iyi insanlar,
mutlu insanlar,
topluma ayak uydurmuş,
kahraman olarak görülen-
Sonra ne yazık ki
bunun da yalan olduğunu fark ettim.
Peki niye bu tür cevaplar
aslında bize çok uygun geliyor?
"İyi, mutlu insan, çalışkan insan..."
Çünkü, insan doğası rahatlık arar.
Hepimizin bir rahat alanda
bulunmaya eğilimi vardır.
Evrim bize bunu getirdi.
İnsan doğası düşünmek istemez.
Olabildiğince adapte olmaya,
alışkanlıklar elde etmeye çalışır.
Ve o yüzden,
aslında çalışıyor olduğu gerçeği de,
bu alışkanlıkların en ağır basanı,
söylenen en büyük yalanlardan biridir.
Çünkü sen çalışıyor olsan,
zaman harcıyor olsan,
yaptığının doğru olduğuna inanırsın.
Sonunda bir şey üreteceğini düşünürsün.
Ama aslında,
sadece çalışmak bunu üretmiyordur.
Şimdi, "veya" çok güzel bir kelime.
Çünkü, çıkış yolu anlamına geliyor.
Ama bu kelimeyi daha da güzel
yapan olay şu ki:
Araya bir tire koyduğumuz zaman,
"son derece alışılmamış"
yani bir yönüyle,
"bohem" anlamına geliyor.
Ve aslında bu tüm yaratıcı insanları,
bilim insanlarını, girişimcileri
tarif eden bir kelime.
Çünkü eğer yaratıcılık, üretkenlik
alışılmış bir şey olsaydı,
bu kadar önemli olmazdı herhalde.
Yani bu insanlar, öyle ya da böyle
bir şeylerin dışına çıkabilen insanlar.
Albert Einstein,
Nikola Tesla...
Bu isimler ve daha birçoğu,
benim kahramanlarım.
Bunları okuyarak büyüdüm.
Hala da olabildiğince bunların
yolundan gitmeye çalışıyorum.
Ama şöyle bir gerçek var ki:
Aslında bu insanlar toplumun
ideal kahramanları değiller.
Herkes Albert Einstein'ın
fiziğe katkılarını bilir.
Ama hiçbirimiz bunu anlatırken
Albert Einstein'ın aslında
eşlerini aldatan bir insan
olduğunu söylemeyiz.
Nikola Tesla, şu an burada kullandığımız
ampullerden radyo alıcılarına kadar
bir sürü şey yapmıştır.
Ama o insanın güvercinlerle bile
insanlarla anlaştığından
daha iyi anlaştığını hiçbir zaman
dile getirmeyiz.
Steve Jobs;
evet, Apple markasını yarattı.
Microsoft'un yaratılmasına bile
öncü oldu bir yanda.
Ama bu adamın, sahiplenmediği
bir küçük kız çocuğu var.
Leonardo Da Vinci;
Biz bir sürü eserini biliyoruz.
Ama aslında işlerini sürekli erteleyen,
bir şeyleri yapmayan bir adam.
Ve belki de en önemlileri:
Ömer Hayyam.
Hala, neredeyse dünyanın her dilinde
Rubailer'i çevrilen,
çok duru bir şekilde
çok fazla şey anlatan,
ve matematiğin temellerini atan
insanlardan birinin,
hedonist bir ayyaş olduğunu
hiçbirimiz dile getirmiyoruz.
Peki neden?
Çünkü, dediğim gibi;
biz rahatlık arıyoruz.
Çoğumuz toplumun yolunda ilerliyoruz.
Bu yol basit aslında.
Hayatımızın zaten ilk 22 yılı
bizim için çizilmiş durumda.
Sonrasında da
iyi bir kariyer, iyi bir evlilik,
mutlu bir hayat algısı var.
Çoğu şeye önem veriyoruz.
Çok fazla çalışıyoruz.
Liseye geçiş sınavı, üniversite sınavı.
4.0 GPA yapmak, master, doktora.
İyi bir evlilik,
çok maaş veren bir iş.
Bunların hepsi için uğraşıyoruz.
Ama bunlar için uğraşırken,
çok azımız niye bunlar için
uğraştığımızı sorguluyor.
Çünkü bunlar bize verildi zaten.
Bunlarla ilgilenmek kolay.
Bunlar bizi rahat yapıyor,
bunlar alışkanlıklar.
Ama bazılarımız için,
tüm bu alışkanlıkların,
tüm bu yolun dışında,
başka bir yol daha var.
Bu bahsettiğim insanlar;
Albert Einstein, Leonardo Da Vinci,
Nikola Tesla.
Hep bu yoldan gitmeye çalışıyolar.
Çünkü aslında şu anki gerçeklik
onları tatmin etmiyor.
Onlar kendi gerçekliklerini
yaratmak istiyorlar.
Olabildiğince farklı oluyorlar,
olabildiğince üretken olmaya çalışıyorlar.
Ve aslında üretme hissi, yaratıcılık
o kadar obsesif bir his ki;
bir şey yapıyorsunuz
ve çalışıyor,
bir sürü insana dokunabiliyorsunuz.
Bu, bağımlılık yapan bir his.
Ve bir noktada,
bu insanların en yakınlarını bile
karşılarına almalarına yol açabiliyor.
Genelde çok söylenen yalanlardan
biri de şudur:
"Bu insanlar, bensiz insanlardır.
Hep toplumu düşünürler.
Kendileri için uğraşmazlar."
Bu çok büyük bir yalan.
Çünkü bu insanlar, dünyada
görebileceğimiz en bencil
insanlardan birkaçı.
Çünkü;
evet, insanlığa çok katkıları oldu.
Ve bununla da motive oldular.
Ama işin özünde,
insan doğa gereği bencil yaratılmış
bir varlıktır.
Ve o insanlar da bu obsesyonu,
artık benim öfori diye tanımlayabileceğim,
bir şeyler üretme algısını,
kendi zevkleri, eğlenceleri için yaptılar.
Ve sonunda insanlığa da
katkı sağlamış oldular.
Şimdi yine gelmeden önce
X-Ray sırasında bir oyundan bahsedildi.
Yaklaşık,
2017 kışında başlamıştım.
Kanserli çocukları motive eden
bir sanal gerçeklik oyunu.
Çok güzel bir süreçti.
Onca çocuğun yüzüne bir
gülümseme katabileceğimi hissettim.
Sadece bilgisayarın
başında oturarak
bir sürü insanın hayatına
dokunabiliyordum.
Ama ben bunu sadece o çocuklar
için yaptığımı söylersem,
hepinize yalan söylemiş olurum.
Çünkü, evet onları mutlu ettim,
ama bir yandan,
ben bunu yaptığımda hissettiğim öfori
o kadar paha biçilemez
bir hissiyattı ki,
aslında beni sürekli bir şeyler
üretmeye, bir şeyler yapmaya
motive eden hissiyat buydu.
Peki, bir soru daha var.
Yaratıcı insan, evet farklı.
Ama iyi mi?
Şimdi, Albert Einstein,
Richard Feynman,
Niels Bohr, Robert Oppenheimer.
Bunların ortak noktası;
hepsi Manhattan Projesi
isimli bir projeye katıldılar.
Bu adamlar;
atom bombasını yapan insanlar.
Bu adamlar; yüzlerce insanın
ölmesine yol açanlar.
Peki, sizce kötü oldukları
için mi yaptılar?
Hayır.
Belki evet, içlerinde zaten
bir insanı öldürme güdüsü yok.
Ama, merak var.
O kadar merak ediyorlardı ki
yapabileceklerini,
atomu parçalayınca oluşabilecekleri.
Bu insanlar zeki insanlar.
Devletin bunu alıp bomba yapacağını
biliyorlardı içten içe,
hissediyorlardı.
Ama yine de buna göz yumdular
ve meraklarının peşinden gittiler.
Merak da obsesif bir duygudur.
Sonuçta, dünyaya yayılan
tüm kötülükler,
bir insanın merak edip Pandora'nın
kutusunu açmasından kaynaklanıyor.
Yani, yaratıcı insanları aslında
"iyi" diye de nitelendirmemek gerekiyor.
O yüzden şunu düşünmeye başladım:
Hani, bunlar iyi insanlar değil,
evet, ideallerimizden çok farklı.
Geriye çok basit bir cevap kalıyor:
Yaratıcı insanların ortak özelliği
aykırı olmaları, farklı olmaları,
bohem olmaları.
Hangi sıfatı kullanırsanız kullanın.
Onlar toplumun bir parçası değil.
Evet, belki şu an ben
onların hepsini "kötü" diye anlattım.
Çünkü bunun nedeni şu-
Ben onların kötü olduğunu düşünmüyorum.
"Yaratıcı insanlar iyi midir
ya da kötü müdür?"
o insanlara sorulacak bir soru değil;
anlamsız.
İyiyle kötü yapay kavramlardır.
Doğada iyi, kötü yoktur.
Sadece hayatta kalan vardır.
İyi ve kötü,
bizim düşüncesel gelişimimizin,
bizim toplumumuzun oluşturduğu
bir kavramdır.
Ve sonuçta toplum çoğunluk.
Kendine "kötü" diye negatif bir sıfat
vermeyeceğine göre,
elbette "iyi"yi verdi.
Ve bu insanlar da toplumdan
bu kadar farklılarsa,
evet, onların yargılarına göre
"kötü" diye adlandırılabilirler.
O yüzden, bir de aklıma şu soru geldi:
Rağmen mi sayesinde mi?
Bu insanlar, tüm bu kötü özelliklerine
rağmen mi bunları başardılar,
sayesinde mi?
Bence cevap:
Sayesinde.
Çünkü tüm bu özellikler,
bir noktada belli başlı dogmalara karşı
bir başkaldırı.
Ve üretkenlik, yaratıcılık zaten
doğası gereği sıfırdan bir şey
yaratmak gerekiyor.
Şu anki kurallara, dogmalara uyarak
bunu yapamazsınız.
Ve bu insanlar aslında, dolaylı yoldan
tüm bu aykırılıkları sayesinde
dünyayı bu kadar güzel bir yer yaptılar.
Çoğu zaman kendimize sormadığımız
bir soru var:
En kötü ne olabilir?
Benim gözümde,
önümüzde bir yol var, basit bir yol.
Çok çalışacaksınız,
başarılı olacaksınız.
İyi üniversitelere gidip
yüksek maaşlı bir iş, mutlu bir evlilik.
Bu, rahat bir yol.
Yani, yapacağınız şey belli;
çok düşünmenize gerek yok.
Sadece adapte olmanız gerekiyor.
Ama bir yol daha var.
O da; bu yolun dışına çıkmak.
Bu zor bir yol.
Zaman zaman size yalnızlık getirecek.
Zaman zaman belki kötüleneceksiniz
çünkü her bilimsel çalışma
iyi olacak diye bir şey yok,
bazen kötü şeyler de olabilir.
Bazen nefret edileceksiniz,
bir kitle tarafından.
Bazen dostlarınız sizi bırakacak.
Ama günün sonunda
belki acı çekseniz de,
mutluluğunuzdan biraz esirgenseniz de,
yine de bu dünyaya hiç varolmayan
bir şey getirmiş olacaksınız.
Ve bence bu bir insanın hayatında
tadabileceği en güzel hissiyatlardan biri.
Bize anlatılan mitler vardır:
Yunan mitolojisi, işte Roma mitolojisi...
Ve bu mitlerde bazen yaratıcılık,
merak, üreticilik gibi kavramlar
kötülenebilir.
Mesela, insan Babil Kulesi'ni yapar.
Ama Tanrı'ya meydan okuduğu için,
Babil Kulesi yıkılır.
Daedalus, kanatlar yapar,
Icarus kibrinden dolayı
güneşe çok yakın uçtuğu için düşer.
Veya biri meraklanıp Pandora'nın kutusunu
açar ve dünya kötü bir yer olur.
Peki ya gerçek dünya
böyle değilse?
Ya gerçek dünyada üretken insanlar
kötülüklerine, kibirlerine
günahlarına rağmen veya günahları
sayesinde tüm bunları yapıyorlarsa?
Ya Icarus güneşe kadar uçmayı başardıysa
ve hâlâ aramızda uçmaya devam ediyorsa?
Teşekkürler.